[Music]
couple caveats to start this off for
those of you who don't know me which is
everyone who doesn't work your KS MC my
name is Justin bowls senior Software
Architect at KS MC I have spent my
career working in just about every
language Under the Sun with the noted
exception of Python so I am obviously an
expert in this territory there are a lot
of really smart people at KS MC who know
a lot about I thought in big data you
should talk to them they're at the table
over here so what I wanted to focus
today on is more some shifts that I see
coming in the industry that affect all
of us whether or not you're working in
Python or dotnet or Ruby or I think
there's some COBOL programmers out there
still probably so that's what I wanted
to look at today so I apologize if
you're looking for a really in-depth
technical talk on Python this isn't it
you can take a half-hour nap and then
some really smart people come up after
me
I will also caveat this by saying that I
have spent the last three weeks with two
to two-and-a-half year olds that we just
adopted and I wrote this speech while I
was in Africa so with with that as our
background let's let's get started so I
wanted to talk a little bit about the
focus of the software industry as a
whole for most of my career has really
been around this idea of we're gonna
write code in in one language and then
we can deploy that code you know before
the internet across all these different
platforms and then with the advent of
the internet obviously we have these
teams that that we have this one code to
to beat all right so back in the day it
was Java right and since we're all Java
programmers this obviously works really
well but there's the idea that you could
write at once and you could run it
anywhere
and it was gonna be great and and the
the problem that we ran into it's at is
if anybody remembers what did they call
internet DLL hell right where you had to
have the right version of the right DLL
is installed at all times Java ran the
same thing yet of the right client
sometimes those clients collided with
one another and what it turned into was
you would just write it once and then
you would debug it everywhere right and
so when we got to the mobile Wars of iOS
versus Android we then repeated the
sense of the past right
nobody wanted to write their app for iOS
and then turn around and write it again
for Android so we created these things
like Appcelerator react native etc and
the great idea was that we would write
this one code base and we deploy it
across all the platforms and it would be
great right and what we found was that
that also didn't work right so there's a
great article I think they're gonna post
this slide deck right so don't worry
about writing down the URL but there's a
great article here on medium and what
about Airbnb RIA abandoning react native
and where Airbnb found was that they
would write their react native app and
then they would have to maintain a
separate code branch to do all the iOS
tweaks and then a third code branch to
do all the Android tweaks and now
they're they're maintaining three code
bases instead of one right which is an
optimal so what we thought was going to
be this great step forward of we only
have to do one we only have to write
this once now we got to write it three
times right set it twice so they went
back to native and and failed on on that
pursuit as well and I feel like we're
doing the same thing again with
JavaScript right so javascript is a
front-end language and if you would like
to argue me on that don't it's a
front-end language it is not a back-end
language I'm sorry no developers it's
not if anybody has ever tried to do
anything with promises they know what
I'm talking about
okay so javascript is not a front-end
language and what we have found
through all of these trials and
tribulations through 20 years of trying
to make one language to do everything is
that one language can't do everything it
couldn't do it in 1998 I can't do it
today right so how do we solve this
problem or why did we run into this
problem deployments and maintenance were
expensive I'm sure people here know or
have stories of you know it took a week
to deploy new code or production right
it takes you know to get through QA to
get through you eighty to get through
you know the actual deployment process
we've got outage windows of ours and
that costs lots of money to
organizations right so what we what we
have run into is an organization or as a
industry I think is a big change that's
that has come and it's come in the form
of everybody's favorite buzz word which
is containers right how many of your
bosses will just use kubernetes and
everything will be fine right but I
think this is exciting
I think containers are exciting for a
lot of different reasons and it's it's
more than just some things that the
sales guys can say during during their
their sales pitches the thing that
excites me most about containers is that
for the first time in a long time we can
actually allow each language to do its
own job that it does really well right
so Python or JavaScript can do the
front-end stuff right Ruby on Rails
dotnet these middle tier API languages
can do their stuff really really well
Python can do all of its great data
analysis and data manipulation stuff
right and we can put all of this stuff
out there as one complete system that
instead of at the beginning of the
project saying we're going to build this
system in Python right so now we have to
figure out how to get Django to work on
the front end and we have to figure out
how to get all of these pieces to work
together and maybe this is an optimal
for this but it
better for that so we're just going to
do that for the entire project right we
don't have to give those concessions any
more we can now use containerization to
make it easier to go through that
deployment process right and we can use
containerization to allow all of these
languages to do what they what they do
really really well so I want to give you
an example of that that we've been
working on recently so here's our
infrastructure so we are collecting data
from sixteen different data sources some
of that data structures and that data is
unstructured Steven will tell you most
of that data is unstructured and he
hasn't slept a lot in the last couple
months but he looks great regardless of
that so it comes in and are really smart
Python guys do a lot of really smart
stuff and they break this stuff apart
and they figure out what it means and
they dump it into a data store and then
our front-end can come in and pick up
that data and in show to the end-user
right and then we're going to use an
Amazon cue simple queue service to be
able to allow our front-end to talk to
the backend that's doing all that
processing right pretty simple for those
of you who have ever written software
you always start with a diagram like
this and it always turns into a diagram
that looks like this right so it's never
that simple
so we had to add a couple more services
we had to add a couple more things we
had to add a couple more process
processing points but the beauty of this
is that despite the fact that we almost
doubled the number of boxes on the
screen from slide 1 to slide 2 our
deployment and our CI CD was not any
more complicated all of these things are
still running in containers
we're just deployed a few more
containers it's all on AWS and so it did
not exponentially increase the amount of
work for our operations for our dev
operations team even though we made it
exponentially more complicated as far as
an infrastructure goes so containers
really allow each language to do what it
does best and then we don't have to go
through and sort of bastard I some of
these languages to get to get some
productivity out of them at the end of
the day and please feel free to stop ask
questions whatever this is not gonna
take half hour so I'm banking on some
audience audience participation the
second thing I want to talk about and I
know there's a talk later on Apache
airflow which is going to be awesome you
guys want to make sure you pay attention
to that
Apache airflow is something that is a
new concept for me and something that
I'm really excited about so but let's
talk about reusable code reusable code
is the holy grail of software
development right everybody wants to
have this perfect dry object-oriented
library of code that you just go pick
your module off the shelf you make a few
adjustments to it right you plug it in
and off you go
right and so your project just
essentially exists of grabbing three or
four things putting them together and
you're done right I've never actually
seen a software project go that way
right you always pull something off the
shelf and you're like wow it doesn't
quite do exactly what I wanted to do and
then inevitably when we get down to the
very crunch time there just ends up
being a lot of copy and pasting and we
don't stick to our dry principles quite
as well as as we intended to whenever we
started the project out right and so you
come to a project a piece of code after
six months and you go what was I
thinking when I wrote this right so I
think what's exciting about a product
like Apache airflow and there are some
other ones as well is it really allows
us to activate this idea of pipe and
filter methodology around writing these
small snippets of code that do something
very specific and then using that tool
to string those snippets of code
together those jobs together and then
and then schedule them so they can run
on a fairly consistent basis or whatever
basis you need them Iran and so I think
this is the first time where I've seen
in action a situation where you actually
do have a snippet of code that you can
pull off the shelf you can plug some
things together and reuse that code not
only within the same project but even
across projects so here's those quick
snapshot of the airflo implementation
like I said there is a talk on that
later today
maybe next I'm not sure exactly what the
schedule is but it there's talk on that
later today I saw it on the schedule so
stay tuned for that because I think you
guys will get a lot more out of that
continuous deployment everyone's
favorite buzzword right now is DevOps
how many people read the reviews of the
iPhone 11 Pro when it came out how many
people were like saw the reviews that
said this is the worst product that
Apple's ever made Apple can't innovate
anymore
they're terrible the reason that you
were seeing this in my opinion is that
everyone is getting used to continuous
deployment every time you log in to some
applications some SAS application that
you're using you see some new features
set right we've got apps on our phone
that update in the background now so you
just open them and there's some new
feature set sitting there for you right
how many times you walk in and you open
an app and you have to hit the skip
button to get past the tutorial right so
we're used to this rapid pace of
innovation and this rapid pace of new
features and when you only release a
product once a year you can't do that
right so then everyone gets upset that
they didn't get this new cool shiny
thing that got rumored because the rumor
gets out of control right so the whole
point of that story is that we as a
software industry have to focus on how
do we get new features out as fast as we
can and how do we get them so that we
can reduce the cost of implementing new
features and how do we push code out
faster right how do we make our users
happier because we're introducing these
new features
that make our applications easier to use
and so we have been looking at a couple
of things around using infrastructures
code we be in KSM seam but we mean not
me at all but that's okay
using infrastructures code to be able to
spin up environments and spend-down
environments using software right and
the idea behind this is that we can take
all of this data that's being created by
all these folks that are doing just
their jobs right everybody's daily job
creates some data point right and so we
can look at all of these data points we
can pack package them up we can then
deploy them in a secure environment
using infrastructures code that allows
individuals to be able to pull some
insights out of those datasets right so
to give you an example of what I'm
talking about we had a client that came
to us and said we have all this really
secure data we cannot allow this really
secure data out of our secure area right
and we said ok and they said but we want
to make it available to people through
an approval process so that they can go
in and they can look at this data and
they can pull insights out of this data
I said ok great so we set up a workflow
system that if they're approved the data
set is sitting out in Azure right and it
connects to Jupiter hub and we spin up a
Jupiter notebook instance and we give
them access to the Jupiter notebook
instance and they can do all their stuff
in Jupiter notebook and everyone's
really excited about it right so cool
thing we spin up all this stuff using
infrastructures code spin it back down
when we're done everybody's excited
about it right except for here's a
little diagram so for anyone who's ever
worked with a client knows that as soon
as you do that they say cool but we
can't actually use that right so they
came back to us and said everybody
actually wants to use tableau and Excel
no one really wants to use Jupiter
notebook so this is all sort of
worthless so thanks for trying
it doesn't work so we went back and said
okay we can we can figure that out and
so all we really had to do was tweak our
solution a little bit and throw a
virtual machine in the middle so now
they connect to a virtual machines
virtual machine connects to the joopa
notebook the virtual machine has tableau
on it and they can do all their stuff
with it right so we can do all of this
stuff by deploying through through
software interfaces and through
infrastructures code and and we can
create these really complex dynamic
environments that are really really
interesting so I will stop rambling here
so just to finish to finish up here
containers reduced cost of deployment
and we can do some really cool stuff
with them Apache airflow gives us the
opportunity to string these different
you know little snippets of code
together and really build a code library
that we can actually have reusable code
and then infrastructure as code really
gives us a lot of opportunity around
using these huge data sets that we're
creating every day and putting them on
to and pulling those insights out of
them in a way that's meaningful and and
useful for businesses and that is all
that I have so thoughts questions
[Applause]
yeah folks have questions for Justin we
can pass the mic around and like get
some feedback or quick things here we go
yes so when you were talking about your
CI CD process not changing with
containers can you kind of describe how
that worked is it the content of the
containers that changed and then you
just deploy containers the same way or
can you unpack that a little bit as I
would the when you're talking about your
your DevOps and CI CD process didn't
have to change when you were using
different languages yeah deploying can
take containers yeah so are we use a
product called circle CI for our
continuous integration deployment we
also use a product called sonar cloud
for static code analysis so when we
commit code it goes through circle CI
goes through sonar cloud make sure that
all that linting is good and then we use
elastic container registry I believe on
AWS and so when we added more components
it was simply a situation where we
created a new repository we hooked it up
to circle CI copied those same scripts
that we had in the previous repository
over to the new one and so that build
process was pretty much flushed out and
then through all of the tools all the
AWS tools we were able to push those new
containers out and get everything
communicating the way we wanted it to
does that answer your question I don't
know if I really did a good job on that
but okay so the point there it's like a
lot of it was pre scripted and we were
able to copy the scripts and just make a
few adjustments to them can you go back
to your slides that blob in tableau so
yeah what is the need of Jupiter hub if
we have the VM tableau in the VM here I
mean so the the need for Jupiter so we
have the VM that sits in the middle the
the need for Jupiter hub is to spend
over tubular notebooks so the people
could do
their analysis within that so they are
doing it in the devil itself right so no
no the VM is tableau is in the VM
tableau was on the VM so it the idea
there was it gave people options so they
could do tableau they could do Excel
they could do power bi or they could do
and if they could use Jupiter notebook
okay so they had all those options there
and then any output that was made from
any of that stuff was then still secured
so that the user couldn't download that
and take it out of that security
environment
[Music]